democrats block a covid relief bill joe
biden continues to fuss and struggle
while the media cover for him
and netflix comes under fire for a film
containing disturbingly pedophilic
images i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show ben shapiro show is
sponsored by expressvpn why haven't you
gotten a vpn yet visit expressvpn.com
before we get to all the news and it is
a varied and wild news cycle
first let's talk about the fact that
you're spending way too much on that
cell phone bill like a lot of money on
your cell phone bill and you don't need
to spend that much on your cell phone
bill
i mean let's be real about this you're
spending a lot because you're paying for
unlimited data are you actually using
unlimited data or are using as it turns
out
very limited data and what you actually
need is to cut down on that cell phone
bill but still get the same exact kind
of coverage that you have
right now well good news for you that's
what pure talk does pure talk will give
you the exact same coverage same towers
same bars as att verizon t-mobile but
it'll cost you half
no contract no excessive fees right now
you can enjoy unlimited talk text and
two gigs of data all for just 20 bucks a
month the average person is saving 400
a year on their wireless bill so grab
your mobile phone dial pal 250
say ben shapiro when you do you save 250
bucks off any iphone
including the no iphone se again that is
pound two five zero
say keyword ben shapiro pure talk usa is
simply smarter wireless there is no
reason to overspend especially these
days you need to
you need to save your money you need to
spend it on things that actually matter
to you
not spend it on a phone company for that
unlimited data that you are not using go
check out pure talk usa right now now
by dialing pound 250 and saying ben
shapiro to save 250 bucks
off any iphone as well including that
new iphone
se okay so we begin at this hour with a
quick
note that today of course is september
11th which is a good time to remember
that we're supposed to be a unified
country i know these are incredibly
divisive times
and people look at each other across the
aisle and we think how about a national
divorce like
we don't seem that we want to live in
the same country anymore well
it's amazing to say that it's been
nearly 20 years since 9 11 but
for those of us who are old enough to
remember 9 11 it was a formative
experience
for a lot of us i know a lot of people
who shifted from left to right in the
aftermath of 9 11. i know a lot of
people who had a revivified sense of
what it meant to be an american after 9
11 it turns out that when america
is under attack from an existential
threat when americans are being murdered
by the thousands
in america's biggest and greatest
landmarks
americans tend to to to resonate to that
and remember what it is that was
supposed to bring us together as
americans and
frankly it's incredible that in the
midst of a great pandemic we can't even
do that again
in the midst of a global pandemic that
has taken at this point nearly 200 000
or about 200 000 american lives that we
can't come together and at least
recognize
why exactly we like each other or why we
want to occupy
the same country and maybe it is that
it's just been too long since 9 11 for
people to remember exactly how we felt
on the morning of 9 11 as we watched
terrorists plow
two civilian airliners into the twin
towers
and as we watched them plow another
civilian airliner into the pentagon
and as a fourth civilian airliner went
down in a field in pennsylvania
but for those of us who are old enough
to remember we remember the
gut-wrenching
horror of watching our fellow americans
people we had no idea their politics we
had no idea
what they believed about the world
having to hurl themselves from the
highest stories of the world trade
center people with families people with
children
watching as firefighters charged into
those buildings knowing full well that
they would probably die
doing that and trying to save other
people's lives
knowing full well that people who are
joining the military and making
sacrifices most of us were not willing
to undertake
to go overseas and protect america that
this was indeed a great country in a
country worth upholding
and that is worth remembering again that
is worth remembering again that what
unites us is supposed to be so much more
than what divides us unfortunately in
today's day and age
maybe it's because we haven't faced down
a 911 maybe it's because we haven't had
a the the spectacularly horrifying
images on tv
of what happened on 9 11 hit the united
states again maybe because
covet isn't an external enemy so much as
just an ever-present threat
maybe for whatever reason we have not
come together
instead we've decided to savage each
other tear each other apart and see each
other
as enemies rather than friends as
enemies rather than brothers
and sisters good indicator of this today
on twitter there's a trending hashtag
that would hashtag all buildings matter
now the ideological contortions you have
to go through
in order to tweet that and believe that
you're saying something good relevant or
moral
are pretty astonishing so presumably
this has meant this this hashtag all
buildings matter is meant as a rebuttal
to the all lives matter rebuttal to
black lives matter
so in order to try and understand the
logic of this you have to go back to
what black lives matter was supposed to
represent
so black lives matter as i've said
before is a term of semantic overload it
can mean several different things one it
can
be the inarguably true and obvious
proposition that black lives matter in
the united states which we all agree
with
then it could mean the black lives
matter organization which is a radical
neo-marxist movement and then it could
mean the black lives matter movement
more generally not the organization but
the movement more generally which argues
that america is systemically racist
and dislikes black americans and
discounts black bodies and tries to harm
black
americans a proposal for which at this
point in american history there's not
only no evidence there's significant
counter evidence
okay all lives matter was meant as a
rebuttal generally speaking to that
second contention
which is that everybody agrees that
black lives matter because black lives
matter just as much as everybody else's
life
okay so people who are advocates of
black lives matter decided that they
were going to hashtag
all buildings matter as though the the
comparison where you say that
the the world trade centers matter well
all buildings matter equally okay this
makes no sense
this makes no sense because the argument
of black lives matter is that black
people are being disproportionately
targeted that america is systemically
racist
okay that that is a bad argument there's
not a lot of data to back that in fact
as i say there's significant counter
data to back that the hashtag all
buildings matter
presumably suggests that certain
buildings were not targeted
well we we know which buildings were
targeted and in fact we know why we were
upset
that those buildings were targeted not
merely because they were landmarks but
because as it turns out they were
holding thousands of human beings
black white and green anybody who thinks
it's an intelligent point to tweet out
all buildings matter at this point
is an idiot and everybody understands
that they're an idiot or should
understand that they're an idiot and
that they're not making a good point
about black lives matter or anything
else
for that matter but to use 911 as in as
an anniversary
for divisiveness to suggest that 911
ought to
immediately be channeled into a debate
about black lives matter
is kind of wild uh the only only thing
that makes it not wild is of course if
you buy into
this theory that america is inherently
bad then you end up in the ta-nehisi
coates position
of writing about the fact that you
watched 911 happen from your apartment
rooftop smoked pot and felt nothing
that's something that ta-nehisi coates
has actually
written about in his books because
america's so systemically terrible that
he didn't feel anything while watching
911 this is something that he wrote
in i believe between the world and me if
you believe that then there really is
nothing that can hold america together
anymore so if 9 11 doesn't mean anything
to you because you weren't born that's
one thing but if you're old enough to
remember 911
if you're old enough to remember what it
felt like and you don't still have that
that churning gut feeling every time you
think
of the horrors of that day and you still
can't think that
like why people would fly a flag in the
aftermath of 911 i remember this i mean
we all remember this
all the flags that went up all around
the united states in solidarity
with each other they had the feeling of
brotherhood and sisterhood that came
along
with 911 the the final record final
realization that we were all part of the
same country and that it was a country
worth upholding that we are a good
country
that when shown against in stark relief
with so many other places around the
world including
the the ideologies of places like
afghanistan and and the taliban and
al-qaeda
that when you're replacing the united
states in stark relief with any place
else on earth this is an amazing amazing
place with amazing people
heroes you know people that don't know
other people
who they are willing to sacrifice their
lives for we should be remembered
we should be reminded of that as we
approach a contentious election when it
appears that violence in the streets is
a real possibility we should remember
all of that okay in just a second we're
going to get to the news of the day
first let us talk about the fact that
you need better employees
you do okay and these days it can be
tough to find really great employees
also it could be really tough to find a
job if you're an employee looking for a
great
employer monica starks could relate she
needed to hire for a pivotal role at her
construction company gs group
she was having a tough time finding the
right person especially with a lot of
candidates out there so she switched to
zip recruiter
zip recruiter doesn't depend on
candidates finding you it finds them for
you it's technology identifies people
with the right experience for your job
and then actively invites them to apply
which is why you should try ziprecruiter
for free
at ziprecruiter.com dailywire and that
is how monica found lamont jenkins she
said zip recruiter sent lemon's profile
to her around five minutes after she
posted her job because he was a great
match
for the role through zip recruiter
monica's company has hired everybody
from accountants to project managers to
field scientists
monica is not the only employer who
loves it here at daily wire we've been
using a zip recruiter
consistently so say that you have a
brand new producer named reckon she
seems quite wonderful
there's only one problem rebecca has a
very avant-garde take on the film cuties
from netflix
a take that i may share but if it goes
badly rebecca may find herself on the
breadlines
nonetheless well this is why you need
zip recruiter
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the very first day
see for yourself how zip recruiter makes
hiring faster and easier try it right
now for free that is correct free
at zip recruiter dot com slash daily
wire that zip recruiter dot com
daily wire if you're an employer keep
your employees in abject terror of being
replaced by somebody better who has a
more conventional take on cuties and if
you're an employee and you're looking
for a job check out daily
check out ziprecruiter right now
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that's ziprecruiter.com
dailywire to find the best employees and
the best employers okay
so news of the day the democrats
continue to block coveted relief
the media are covering for them so what
you've seen is senate
republicans fail to advance bill senate
republicans fail to advance bill no
that's not what happened here
what actually happened here is that
senate democrats who are in the minority
utilized
that jim crow relic according to barack
obama the senate filibuster
to filibuster a coveted relief package
kamala harris voted in favor of that
filibuster
so democrats used the filibuster to kill
a coveted relief package just a few
weeks after using
that jim crow hallmark the filibuster in
order to kill police reform proposed by
republican senator tim scott
so it seems like democrats are very much
willing to use
jim crow relics when it serves their
interests they are willing to use any
institution of power or get rid of any
institution of power in pursuit
of their goals which is one of the
reasons why republicans have very little
trust that democrats are going to abide
by any rules of the game when it comes
to upholding american institutions it's
one of the reasons
why i among other conservatives deeply
fearful that democrats who have now
pledged that they wish to pack the
courts that they wish to get rid of the
senate filibuster that they wish to add
states
could systematically change the nature
of american government
if they achieve a majority in the senate
and the presidency of the united states
in 2020. so why are democrats doing this
the answer is obvious they would love to
see
the economy tank just before the
election and ensure that joe biden wins
election
according to the new york times
prospects for any additional stimulus to
address the coronavirus pandemic's
devastating toll before the election
darkened considerably on thursday when a
whittled down republican plan
failed in the senate on a partisan vote
democrats voted it unanimously to block
the proposal from advancing
calling it inadequate to meet the
mounting needs for federal aid in the
latest indication of a lack of political
will to reach an agreement even as
critical federal aid for individuals and
businesses has run dry
it was a nearly party-line vote whose
outcome was never in doubt the proposal
amounted to a fraction of the 1 trillion
plan republicans had offered negotiation
with democrats who in turn were
demanding
more than twice as much well the reason
that the republicans then proposed a
slim down bill is they said you can't
agree on any of the ancillary stuff in
the bill
so let's just at least agree that we
should extend some unemployment benefits
for a little while we should make sure
that people have enough money to pay
their rent for the next month or so
a failure to compromise would leave
millions of jobless americans in
potentially dire straits
as they exhaust traditional jobless
benefits and states run out of
additional funds
trump steered to the unemployed by
executive order last month it would also
strand a wide swath of small business
owners who have endured steep drops in
revenue
as the pandemic chilled economic
activity senator pat roberts republican
of kansas said quote along with the
pandemic of cove 19 with a pandemic of
politics
looking to the house for that matter our
colleagues across the aisle is a sort of
dead end street
this is right senator marco rubio of
florida republican he said congress
isn't going to pass more covenant 19
relief before the election
and again the reason for this is because
democrats have decided that they will
benefit
from a lack of relief at this point
remember democrats have never met a
spending bill they don't like
except for this one because the spending
bill that they don't like
is the one that would presumably help
trump have a possibility of winning
re-election or help republicans who are
in very contentious senate races there
are a lot of very close senate races
around the nation right now so combine
the alarmism that democrats are
performing about covid
and the possibility of a second wave in
new york new jersey with their
unwillingness
to push forward relief and it's pretty
obvious what is going on here
people are playing politics the media
are helping out by immediately running
headlines about how the republicans have
failed here it's the republicans who
it's not the democrats who are
obstructionists it's the republicans who
failed meanwhile the same media
are pushing the idea that the virus is
continuing to be a complete threat to
all americans
of all sorts the new york times ran with
a research letter from harvard
that talked about how covet 19 is quite
a life-threatening disease in people
of all ages that research letter from
harvard found that among the 3
22 young adults hospitalized with
covenant 19 88 died about 2.7
percent one in five required intensive
care one in ten needed a ventilator to
assist with breathing
among those surveyed 99 patients three
percent could not be sent home from the
hospital or were transferred to
facilities for ongoing care or
rehabilitation
the study quote establishes that
covenant is a life-threatening disease
in people of all ages
okay now the reason that this study is
incredibly stupid is because of course
number one the people who are young that
you are talking about are
largely people with pre-existing
conditions over one-third were obese one
quarter extremely so roughly one in five
had diabetes one and seven had
hypertension
but more than that you're talking about
the number of people who got covet who
were then hospitalized you're talking
about a subset of a subset of a subset
you're like young people
who got coveted were then hospitalized
for covet
and who had pre-existing conditions yes
it turns out that a disease can be very
dangerous to people who are already
hospitalized but the question is how
many of those people are actually
hospitalized
in the first place when you're talking
about young people the answer is not
very many young people are not being
hospitalized at a at a high rate when it
comes to covid19 but again there's a
narrative that is attempting to be
driven
by the media and that is covet is an
ever-present threat particularly to
everybody in
the united states including young people
this is an
anti-data perspective it's the reason
why the ap ran a story yesterday
suggesting that three teachers had died
because schools reopened
none of the three teachers actually died
as a result of contact with students
so you're just seeing alarmism in the
media combined with democratic
intransigence on providing any sort of
relief before the election
the conclusion they want you to draw is
that this is an unchecked pandemic
about which the federal government is
doing nothing and that of course is
donald trump's fault
now this has been driven forward of
course by trump's foolhardy decision to
speak with bob woodward and then say on
tape to bob woodward that he downplayed
the pandemic as i said yesterday the
narrative that is being driven by this
is actually not true so the narrative
that the democrats are trying to drive
is that trump lied people died
right the trump knew full well in early
february this thing was airborne and
super dangerous way more dangerous than
the flu and then you lied about it for
months
okay this assumes a level of knowledge
and intent on the part of president
trump that i think is utterly not in
evidence as bob woodward himself
recognized the reason he didn't report
trump's comments at the time
is because he didn't know whether trump
was puffing or knew what the hell he was
talking about because literally no other
health official
was saying that this thing was airborne
and multiple times as deadly as the flu
in early february that was not a thing
that was being said
okay nonetheless jonathan carl of abc
news questioned trump about that
yesterday said why did you lie to the
american people
and as we'll see the biden campaign is
already running ads on this
why did you lie to the american people
and why should we trust what you have to
say
terrible question and the phraseology i
didn't lie
what i said is we have to be calm we
can't be panicked
i knew that the tapes were these were a
series of phone calls that we had mostly
phone calls
and bob woodward is somebody that
i respect just from hearing the name for
many many years
not knowing too much about his work not
caring about his work but i thought
it would be interesting to talk to him
for a period of
you know calls so we did that
okay so again why would you speak to bob
woodward because you thought it was
interesting like this is just setting a
trap
for yourself and then yesterday of
course trump then talked about how much
tv he had watched which is always a bad
look
in the middle of a pandemic or a
presidential election he talked about
all the shows that he had watched over
the past 24 hours
which of course provided fodder for joe
biden
i watch some of the shows i watch liz
mcdonald she's fantastic i watched
fox business i watched
lou dobbs last night sean hannity last
night
tucker last night laura
i watched uh fox and friends in the
morning you watching shows
you don't have to go too far into the
details they cover
things that are it's really an amazing
thing
okay so as you will see this became
fodder for biden ad again the entire
biden campaign is predicated on the fact
that he can stay in his basement and
just rip on trump and the media will do
his heavy lifting for him
because when he steps out of basement
things get very ugly for him we'll get
to joe biden
in just one second first let's talk
about how now is not a great time to go
to the auto parts store in fact as it
turns out
never is a great time to go to the auto
parts store you're gonna go there it's
gonna cost you too much money they're
gonna have to order the part online
anyway they might offer you
an upsell based on whether you are a
commoner or whether you are an auto
parts pro
instead why don't you just go check out
rockauto.com it is much much easier than
walking into a store and someone's
manning quick answers to things like is
your odyssey an lx or an ex and then
they usually just have to order the part
online anyway and
they upcharge you for it instead go
directly to the source with rockauto.com
rockauto.com will always offer the
lowest prices possible rather than
changing prices based on what the market
will bear like airlines do i spend up to
twice as much for the same parts like
say you happen to need a delphi fg 1456
fuel pump assembly
for 2005 to 2010 honda odyssey and it
cost like 354 bucks at a big chain store
that is the kind of thing you could get
at rock auto for 217 bucks
rockauto.com is a family business that
serves auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com they're always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts the rockauto.com catalog it
is unique it is remarkably easy to
navigate
they have amazing selection reliably low
prices all the parts your car will ever
need check them out at rockauto.com
head out head out to rockauto.com right
now see all the parts available for your
car or truck and write shapiro in there
how did you hear about us box so they
know that we sent you again right
shapiro and they're how to hear how did
you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you okay so
joe biden
his entire campaign has been predicated
on orange man bad and he continued that
trend yesterday he put out an ad about
trump
why is trump watching so much tv and
again all trump has to do is not
right all trump has to do is not just
deprive biden of the air and biden will
keel over politically speaking
that because once he actually has to
talk as we'll see joe biden gets himself
in all sorts of trouble all sorts of hot
water
anyway here is the biden out against
trump watch
some of the shows i watched liz mcdonald
she's fantastic
i watched uh lou dobbs last night
sean hannity last night tucker last
night
laura and then it runs the counter of us
yesterday
versus minutes of tv watch
and then it concludes minutes of
television watched 480 u.s coveted
deaths yesterday 1176 now i have a
question if trump were watching less tv
would fewer people have died the answer
of course is no
but again this is this is trump kind of
shooting himself in the foot now
the reason i keep saying that trump has
to avoid giving biden
this sort of air this sort of oxygen is
because when biden is deprived of the
trumpian oxygen upon which he lives
he heals over so yesterday joe biden had
a
rough day in terms of interviews there's
a reason that on 9 11 he has decided
he's not going to politics he says he's
pulled all of his ads i've seen no
evidence he's pulled all of his ads
thus far on 9 11. he says he's not going
to do any interviews today
which maybe that's about 911 or maybe
it's about the fact that he doesn't like
doing interviews i mean the past several
days he has done like one interview and
it went really really poorly
in any case here's how the interviews
went yesterday for joe biden so in the
middle of an interview he mocked trump
over trump
making claims about biden's health and
he lost his train of thought in the
middle of mocking trump
for going after his mental health here
is joe biden wandering off into the
into the blithering wilderness
i mean this idea of you know slow joe
i anyway i i shouldn't laugh about it
because uh
anyway donald trump uh just look at us
both watch us
and determine whether or not you think
um
i'm misleading anyone not you perturb
personally but the public
you know look at me judge me based on i
know what the job
takes um yeah slow joe why would they
call me slow joe
uh what was over here is there pudding
uh uh
is it early bird time yeah that's that's
a good look
hey bret bear ask biden spokesperson
because this has come up recently
whether biden is using a teleprompter
during interviews because there's an
interview that he was doing
uh with uh some labor union in which
somebody asked him a question
and he literally says in the interview i
want you to scroll up
okay now as somebody who operates with a
teleprompter right
i don't use this teleprompter on the
show i'll tell you exactly when i use
the teleprompter okay the only time i
ever use the teleprompter on the show
is if i'm reading an ad which you'll
know or
if i'm making a pitch for the
subscribers which you'll know or at the
very beginning
make that little intro at the beginning
of the show that's the only time i use
the teleprompter
all the other times i'm not using the
teleprompter i'm just staring into
camera and when i do interviews i'm not
using the teleprompter either because
during interviews that would be
incredibly distracting and very weird
no one uses a teleprompter during
interviews that's called cheating right
you don't do that
but joe biden's spokesperson was asked
whether
biden uses a teleprompter during
interviews and he has literally no
answer it's it's very very awkward stuff
has joe biden ever used a teleprompter
during local interviews
or to answer q a with supporters brett
we are not going to engage this is
this is straight from the trump campaign
exactly they're using it and what it
does
and what it does brett is it's trying to
distract the american people i'm just
they're using it they talk about it
every day can you say yes or no that's
because they talk about it every day
brad because they don't have
a coherence well you have an answer yes
or no
brett they talk about it every day
because they don't have a coherent
argument for why donald trump
deserves re-election deserves four more
years we know that he lied to the
american people we know that he has not
uh shown leadership during this crisis
and they are desperate to throw anything
they can against the wall to try to
distract from that fact i understand but
you can't answer the question
correct correct because the fact is that
joe biden is using teleprompter during
interviews because he is in declining
mental health we all know this his
decline is obvious to everyone
and that's why his interviews are going
really really badly so he did an
interview with jake tapper yesterday
in which he he did a bunch of stuff that
really was not beneficial to joe biden
so he suggested that um he tried to deny
trump credit for renegotiating nafta so
he had said over and over that he wanted
to renegotiate nafta they never did it
and tapper was like well trump did it
shouldn't he give him credit and biden's
like
no and tapper looks at him incredulously
it's pretty amazing tv now when you ran
for president
and when barack obama ran for president
you both said you would renegotiate
nafta
you didn't he did does he deserve credit
for that
no i think we remember he didn't he
wasn't the one that pushed that
particular one the past
the house amended the bill you
renegotiated nafta
and you didn't is the point i mean
because we had a republican congress
that wouldn't go along with us
renegotiating it
but doesn't he deserve some credit for
that it's better the usmca is better
than nafta it is better than nafta
um so um yeah yeah that pause from jake
tapper is everything like can you
believe this guy
it's pretty it's pretty amazing so good
stuff right there from dubai and
speaking of good stuff from joe biden he
also
said that it was not a bad idea to give
china most favored nation status when it
came to world trade
which is a weird take considering that
china has used its most favored nation
status to cheat on trade
to strengthen its own regime and to
ensure that it can continue with its
perpetuation of tyranny in hong kong
as well as in zhang province here is
jake tapper questioning biden and biden
again making a boo-boo
a lot of people think that
allowing china into the world trade
organization which he supported
extending most favored nation status to
china which you supported
that those steps allowed china to take
advantage of the united states
by using our own open
trade deals against us oh do you think
in retrospect that you were naive about
china no
here's the thing in the context of that
we want china to grow
we wanted china to grow i mean if trump
can't use that in an ad we wanted china
to grow
as china meanwhile unleashes the the
coronavirus on the rest of the world
and completely destroys hong kong's
freedoms and subjects a million and a
half weaker muslims
to genocidal tyranny yeah good good job
there joe again
this is why trump has to deprive him of
the oxygen of trump
right you just got to stop with with the
trump stuff if you stop at the trump
stuff
all you get is this crazy old bat right
in a second we're going to show you more
of the crazy old bat we'll get to that
in just one moment first
let us talk about the fact that when you
are running a business hr issues can
absolutely kill you don't start a
business to worry about hr but hr issues
can come
and bite you directly on the but we're
talking wrongful termination suits
minimum wage requirements
labor regulations you need somebody
who's going to handle your hr you just
do particularly as your company grows
beyond being a few people hr manager
salaries they are not cheap
they average 70 000 bucks a year can you
afford 70 000 bucks a year just for hr
compliance
probably not instead why not check out
bambi it's spelled b-a-m-b-e-e
it was created specifically for small
business you can get a dedicated hr
manager
craft hr policy and maintain your
compliance all for just 99 bucks a month
which is a great way of ensuring that
your company not only runs smoothly and
in compliance with law but limits your
legal liability because if you don't
have hr people
bad news guys you might end up with an
enormous amount of liability you had not
particularly foreseen from onboarding
determinations
bambi will customize your policies to
fit your business and help you manage
your employees day-to-day all for just
a month month to month no hidden fees
cancel any time you didn't start your
business because you wanted to spend
time on hr compliance go to bambi.com
shapiro right now to schedule your free
hr audit that is b-a-m-b-e dot com
shapiro bam to the b-e-e dot com shapiro
go check them out right now and they'll
give you a free hr audit and
you gotta get your hr in order i mean
it's just something that as a business
owner i'm telling you get your hr
in order okay so back to joe biden and
probably
joe biden's biggest boo-boo in that jake
tapper interview is he essentially
says that the reason that trump won in
2016 was because of racism he suggests
that counties that voted twice for
barack obama and then flipped to trump
did that because of inherent american
racism in response to trumpian dog
whistling so we are now back to barack
obama the bitter clingers are the bad
guys and hillary clinton the deplorables
are the bad guys
why democrats feel the necessity to
constantly go to it's a bunch of racists
supporting my opponents
now vote for me i i don't understand it
other than just the
the deep rooted disdain that so many
democrats have
for people who live in the middle of the
country and in rural areas particularly
and their own self-righteous belief that
they are the only anti-racism crusaders
in the country
and therefore that anyone who opposes
them whether it be mitt romney who joe
biden remembers had wanted to put you
all back in chains or donald trump
that all of those other people are
racist and the people who support them
are racist here is joe biden calling his
political opponents racist
we're in macomb county michigan right
now
this is a county that president obama
and you carried
twice and then president trump carried
by 12 percentage points in 2016.
why do you think so many of these voters
turned against the democratic party in
2016.
i think it was the feeling that they
were taken for granted
i don't know that for a fact and i think
that he
he used that dog whistle on race
now it's a bull horn okay so
again is that is that smart politics by
job and the answer is no which is why
again trump's
biggest political malfeasance here is
putting himself front and center i know
trump likes the attention i know he
wants the camera on him the more the
camera is on joe biden and kamala harris
the more they talk the worse it is for
them
as i have said before elections are a
referendum on one of the two candidates
whoever the referendum is on
loses in 2016 the misimpression from the
media is that
what was going to happen is it was going
to be a referendum on donald trump it
was not in fact a referendum on donald
trump it was a referendum on hillary
clinton
it was a referendum on hillary clinton
because she had a 30-year history of
alienating american voters which is why
even though she won the popular vote by
driving out votes in california and new
york
in the middle of the country people did
not show up for her donald trump won
wisconsin
with fewer absolute votes than mitt
romney lost wisconsin in 2012.
so that ain't about trump driving out
new votes that is about people not
showing up for hillary clinton
well the same thing could easily happen
with joe biden because the more you see
of him the less you like him
so donald trump needs to remove himself
from the stage right accent
stage left followed by bear like get off
the stage right now president trump and
let
joe biden be the center of attention you
don't have to be the center of attention
the more joe biden is the center of
attention
the worse he looks now meanwhile the
entire culture has decided to press
forward
with its narratives on racism because
they think that this is the way they're
going to drive trump from the stage
is by suggesting that america is
systemically racist across the board and
every cultural institution will be
hijacked in order to push forward
this particular push we'll get to that
in just one second first
let us talk about how you protect your
online data are there a lot of viruses
out
there right now there's new ransomware
viruses that are coming along nearly
every day that are designed to basically
lock key files for you unless you pay
the money
it's really really bad stuff this is why
you need pcmatic it's a next-generation
anti-virus
designed to stop modern threats like
ransomware independent testing from av
tests just named pcmatic a top performer
in the cyber security industry giving it
the best performance award for 2019
only pcmatic has american research
development and support pcmatic's
competition is foreign made often in
countries where malware originates
pcmatic blocks annoying and malicious
ads for hassle-free web browsing
makes your computers faster and more
reliable even after years of use
pcmatic protects windows computers
including xp vista windows 7 8 and 10
windows servers max macbooks and android
phones and tablets pcmatic is just 50
bucks for five devices for one year with
a full 30 day money back guarantee if
you act now
pcmatic has offered my listeners a free
month of security protection with the
purchase of an
annual license to access this offer go
to pcmatic.com to get that world-class
security that keeps your computers
running great go to pcmatic.com
that is slash pcmatic.com
go check them out right now protect your
computer in a second we're going to get
to
the cultural narratives that are being
pushed and we'll get to
people blaming climate change for the
fires in california as it turns out that
is not particularly accurate we'll get
to that in a second first as part of our
daily wire audience there are a number
of ways to take in the podcast you can
listen on apple podcast spotify or
another podcast app
you can also watch our podcast at
youtube facebook or over at
dailywire.com here's the bottom line
we're making our content available to
you anywhere you want to watch or listen
and now we're introducing a new upgraded
experience daily wire is now on apple tv
and roku so members can enjoy all of the
visual elements on this podcast on your
big screen
either live or on demand find the daily
wire on apple tv or roku and download it
today you have to be an insider member
to watch live head on over to
dailywire.com
shapiro use code watch at checkout to
get 15 off your membership purchase
the deal won't last long so act fast if
you want live shows on your big screen
plus the one of a kind highly coveted
leftist year's tumblr again that is
dailywire.com
shapiro to get 15 off with codewatch
download the daily wear on your apple tv
and roku today
also another great episode of the sunday
special it is coming up this weekend
former secret service agent conservative
political commentator dan bongino
joins me as we talk about big picture
issues like social media censorship
impeachment
and spygate he is the expert on that and
the radical left's role in the riots and
looting taking place across the country
so
head on over to dailywire.com or listen
on apple podcast spotify wherever else
you get your podcast here's a little bit
of what the sunday special sounded like
you can get the two biggest scandals of
our time
wrong in the media you can say spygate
was a hoax it wasn't
and collusion was real it wasn't and
you get a pulitzer prize
alrighty so go check that out right now
it is definitely worth the watch
really really interesting stuff
meanwhile you are
watching the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
meanwhile the culture wars continue a
pace so last night was the nfl
opener i can assume that the ratings are
going to suck this year just like they
sucked last year it turns out that when
you politicize everything people want to
remain apolitical
people get uptight and i understand all
of the folks out there on the left who
keep saying
you know you keep saying you just want
sports to be sports when were sports
ever just sports
when it didn't infuse the field of play
that is the answer you want the actual
answer the answer is when it didn't
infuse the field to play
athletes always spoke out about stuff
charles barkley was on the cover of
sports illustrated in the early 90s
wearing like chains suggesting that he
was a slave right i mean like
this has been a part of american sport
for a long time when americans start to
get up tight is when they sit down to
watch the game and then they are
preached to
that is not the same thing as athletes
speaking out athletes have always spoken
out
and that's fine they're americans they
get to speak out just like everybody
else doesn't mean that we have to
take their their their words with any
level of seriousness like i don't think
lebron james
actually knows anything about politics i
think he knows very very little about
politics he that is not his field of
expertise i know nothing about
rebounding
and lebron james knows nothing about
politics but that doesn't mean
that when i turn on a game and i am
preached at by a bunch of people who
know nothing about politics
that's not alienating within the
confines of the court within the
confines of the field
people expect to get a product that has
to do with the court or the field
not a bunch of propaganda about
particular political points of view
this is why the nfl is so unbelievably
stupid for getting super political
on the field of play so the nfl has
decided that they're going to
put giant letters reading end racism in
end zones
which of course will totally end racism
like all the white supremacists out
there they're going to look at the
at the end zones of the nfl and they're
going to be like wow
that end zone says to end racism done
hiring discrimination finished right
redlining
soft redlining self-segregation it's
over man because that says end racism
in the end zone okay what this really is
is corporate virtue signaling
so the nfl will continue to make bucks
from people
who purchase based on political likes
and dislikes what it really ends up
doing of course is removing all ability
to have just normal kind of
non-political water cooler talk which is
kind of important right
when you hang out with your friends you
spend most of your time talking about
politics or
did it used to be that football was like
the go-to at thanksgiving when you had
nothing else to talk about with your
crazy uncle
regardless of your political side you
couldn't talk about anything so you
talked about how much the lions suck
and that was the way this used to work
not anymore so roger goodell made a huge
mistake
by first uh allowing holland kaepernick
to know allowing everybody else to kneel
he should have said right from the
outset the same thing that david stern
said back in the 90s
the national anthem is part of the game
you're going to stand for it america is
a is a good place this doesn't seem
particularly controversial
and if you want to say what you want to
say off the field enjoy they have every
right to say what you want to say off
the field on the field you're working
for the business
which by the way is how every other
business in america functions okay but
apparently
not for athletes so roger goodell has
decided to cave to this sort of nonsense
and the predictable result is fewer
people are going to
tune in to watch the games here's roger
goodell overtly politicizing the nfl now
you can talk about so many things that
have happened
to help our country get to a better
place
and sports has been a big big influence
on that
and you know we're not here to make
political statements we're we're here to
help
make our communities better
um oh so you're not here to to make a
political take it's not political when
you put end racism in end zones the
underlying supposition being that racism
is indeed the chief factor in american
life it's not political
as it turns out when you allow the
players to put on their helmets the
names of various supposed victims of
american racism so i guess we'll get a
michael brown helmet even though he was
a person who
attacked a police officer will probably
get a jacob blake helmet despite the
fact that he was an alleged rapist
we'll probably get a rashard brooks
helmet despite the fact that richard
brooks
attacked the police two police officers
and tried to tase them after stealing a
taser from one of them
how's the nfl going to screen for that i
remember when the nfl wouldn't allow
dallas players to pay tribute to the
cops after several cops were shot a few
years back
okay but but it's not political you see
when roger goodell pushes this
except for how political it is so this
all broke out into the open last night
in a couple of ways
so the miami dolphins who will go 2 and
14 this year as is their want
they stayed in the locker room for the
national anthem and then they released a
statement about why they were staying in
the locker room for the national anthem
we need owners with influence and
pockets bigger than ours
to call up officials and flex political
power
when education is not determined by
where we reside
and we have the means to purchase what
the doctor prescribed and you fight for
prison reform and innocent lives
and you repair the communities that were
tossed to the side
and you admit you gained from it and you
swallowed your pride
and when greed is not the compass but
love is the guide and when of course
don't punish skin color
but punish the crime until then we'll
just skip the long production
and stay inside oh so the so bad poetry
is what they're going to do
i also do enjoy how every single video
that is ever cut by celebrities has them
speaking
in three-word phrases and then cutting
to another celeb it really makes a huge
difference
also i'm amused by nfl players who are
among the highest earners in america
suggesting that only the owners have
systemic power or money to actually help
heal all of this stuff
and their big stand is going to be what
to stay in indoors for the national
anthem because the national anthem is
super bad
america is to blame for all of the
problems in american life it's america
and america's systems okay so this
again took sort of center stage last
night the kansas city chiefs were
playing the houston texans they did this
in kansas city they had some socially
distanced crowds there a couple of those
like 17 000 fans
showed up in in kansas city and um the
players before the game decided to link
arms
in a show of unity now i know that there
are some people who think that this is
you know this is better than kneeling
for the end it is better than kneeling
for the anthem
i just i literally don't understand what
the show of unity is in favor of or
against
like racism bad yeah i think we all
agree on that but if this idea is that
you're making a show of courage
by standing against racism also death
bad cancer bad can we get some some
shows of solidarity
and the underlying implication is what
people object to which is that america
is a deeply racist country and that if
you don't stand
then you are then you are obviously okay
with racism so people started booing
this and some people were shouting trump
2020 and this led everybody in the
sports media to get very very upset of
course
what's really going to happen is people
are just going to turn off because they
don't like being called implicit racists
if they're if they don't enjoy being
preached at about their their evil
racism for not supporting x y or z
there was also the denver broncos put
out a photo of their players
going out to some sort of rally that
said if you ain't with us you against us
and nobody knows exactly what they're
supposed to be with or against but
here's my basic rule
if somebody ever says that to me i'm
against you that is my basic rule if you
ever say if you're not with us you're
against us i'm against you
because i'm not going to be blackmailed
into into that sort of ideological
virtue signaling that sort of partisan
virtue signaling it's not just
sports of course it also happens along
the lines of entertainment
so netflix's ceo was out there
propagandizing you may have noticed that
during the black lives matter movement
netflix began to propagandize on on its
main screen
you know they're putting forward black
stories and and again a lot of these
movies are good i've seen a lot of these
movies
but the idea that netflix is making a
big difference by by pushing
education via movies i'm sorry this is
just
sure sure it is so here was the uh here
is the head of netflix
talking about the consequences of
slavery and how bad america is
is a very very rich man talking about
the evils of the american system of
course
as a consequence of slavery jim crow and
housing policy
black families in america have about
one-tenth of the wealth
of white families if we're going to
start to close that
economic and power gap we need black
banks to be able to invest in the black
community
if every major corporation takes one
percent of their cash
and deposits it in a black bank it will
be
transformative in that sector okay well
actually the reason
that people can't get loans typically
has more to do with income and ability
to pay back loans than the race of the
people giving the loans
and the fact remains no matter who owns
the banks banks are not going to give
loans to people who are unlikely to pay
back the loans
and even if you take your money to put
in a black bank unless the black bank is
poorly run it's not going to give
loans to people who are unlikely to pay
back the loans right banks are in the
business
of making loans that they expect to
receive income on that is that is
literally what they do
which which does bring up this all of
this
kind of corporate virtue signaling does
bring up the
this is the 50th anniversary of an essay
that was written by milton friedman that
is now getting all sorts of flack i'll
get to that in a second first i just
want to make one more example of this
lululemon you want to talk about
corporations virtue signaling and making
everything political lululemon
put out a poster i'm not kidding a
workshop
september 17th okay a workshop to unveil
historical erasure and resist capitalism
this is a real thing resist capitalism
lululemon the people who charge 100
bucks for yoga pants for suburban rich
white ladies
they want to decolonize gender and
resist capitalism
okay so number one i don't think you can
decolonize gender through yoga pants
yoga pants seem kind of gendered
just gonna put that out there for all
the dudes in the audience they know what
i'm talking about
turns out that yoga pants guy's kind of
into them
not wearing them looking at them that's
just a reality of life
but beyond that lululemon resisting
capitalism is um it's a hell of a
statement from lululemon
i don't believe them i don't believe
them but again all of this
is is based on a notion
that we are a better country and we're a
better society when our corporations get
super political
and when they start looking down the
road at the rest of american society
okay this runs in direct opposition to
an essay that was originally written by
milton friedman about 50 years ago
actually exactly 50 years ago it was an
essay in which he talked about
shareholder capitalism
and he said that the basic job of a
corporation is to pursue profit on
behalf of its shareholders
now milton friedman was not an advocate
of corporations engaging in regulatory
capture
right trying to set up monopolies he was
not an advocate of corporations trying
to
set regulatory standards such that no
one else could get into business
he was not in favor of people violating
labor laws and that's not what milton
friedman was talking about what he was
talking about
is that when a corporation decides to
virtue signal with somebody else's money
they're either taking money away from
the shareholders or from their workers
or from the consumers
whose prices they have to increase at
the job of a corporation is to provide
goods and services at the best possible
price to the most possible consumers and
to pay
its employees what they deserve
on the basis of making that sort of
money and competition ensures
that the wages go up which by the way
they have because when you have multiple
companies competing for the same workers
then the wages go up
okay this is now considered very bad and
so the new york times magazine
put together an entire issue an entire
compendium on the evils of shareholder
capitalism because the real
essence of corporations should be social
do-gooderism
because i want netflix setting my social
standards as we'll see may not be a
great idea
i want lululemon telling me about
resisting
i want the nfl virtue signaling about
race in america
that's what i want i want nike making
statements about kneeling for the
national anthem
well actually all i want for my
corporations is that they give me the
products and services i want at a price
that i am willing to pay
that is really what i'm looking for from
them and that they pay their employees
what their employees deserve on the open
market that's pretty much it
but anand garad garadhas
who writes for new york times magazine
he has
an incredible piece in new york times
magazine talking about the evils
of shareholder capitalism he says today
in america somebody will be laid off
right after his or her company announced
record earnings
someone's hours will be cut without
notice someone's water will be poisoned
by fracking
and among the pantheon of villains they
can thank is milton friedman okay milton
friedman was not in favor
of environmental degradation okay in
terms of cutting somebody's hours
that may be necessary in order to ensure
that consumers still get the best
possible price
in a competitive market okay but
this really goes to what you think the
purpose of an economy is and this is
something that actually spans the
the gamut right to left there are a lot
of people on the right who believe that
the purpose of an economy is to quote
unquote create jobs or provide meaning
that is not what an economy
is for an economy is to preserve
property rights and get you the best
products and services at a price you are
willing to pay consensually that's what
a market is for that is all the things
the market is for it is not to provide
you meaning
it is not to provide you joy it is not
designed in order to provide you
your purpose in life that's supposed to
be provided by social institutions by
family
by all the things that provide you
meaning and the market is not designed
to quote unquote create jobs the market
is designed to create jobs as a side
product
of creating goods and services right
that is that is what a market is
designed to do
but everybody wants to turn the market
into a human tool this is why it drives
me
up a wall when i hear conservatives
people on the right the kind of common
good conservatives
talk about well you know the markets
weren't designed with
human needs in in human needs in in
that in forefront position well the
markets weren't designed period the
market is based on a certain
basic human truth your labor belongs to
you and you get to alienate it as you
see fed
that's the entire thing and property
rights in your labor deserve to be
protected
that's that's the whole market it's just
a recognition that you as an individual
have rights that is what a market is it
is not a system quote unquote designed
it is not quote unquote designed to
achieve particular ends
it is a wonderful byproduct of that
system that it happens to achieve
particular ends but it is a moral system
because it assumes that you have control
over your own labor and you can alienate
it and make deals with others and engage
in consensual
back and forth with other people but
according to anand garad hadas
friedman criticizes business people from
straying from their lane making money
and worrying about social good
window dressing business people should
not assume quote unquote governmental
functions
of tending to the public welfare and
then he says on that point i actually
agree but here's the thing
friedman militantly condemns the
business person who enters the public
realm to be charitable to be kind to
employees to invest in the commons
because he wants all of these functions
to be left to government
okay well but that is the i mean that's
kind of right i mean if a
corporation takes money and then takes
the money and just gives it away
they are presumably taking it from
shareholders who have invested their
money
or they're upping prices in order to pay
for that or they're taking the money
away from their workers those are the
only source of money that comes into a
corporation
what this really is is an argument that
capitalism is bad and corporations
should run the world it's amazing the
same people who say that corporations
are evil
also say that they want corporations to
donate to their favorite social justice
causes
corporations who fall for this are out
of their minds
because these same people are going to
come after your corporations full scale
by the way anand jaradhas his piece in
the new york times magazine was so crazy
so crazy that the new york times
magazine had to cut it okay here's the
end of the piece quote
milton freeman's legacy is tragic i'm
not being hyperbolic i'm being totally
literal because i've seen their faces
and have told their stories when i say
that a great many people
needlessly suffered and died because he
lived
great many people needlessly suffered
and died because milton friedman lived
milton friedman's
economic program was adopted more and
more broadly over the course
of the latter half of the 20th century
raising literally billions of people
from abject poverty
slicing excessive poverty on planet
earth
by up to 80 percent over the last
several decades
ensuring free trade ensuring property
rights and
all the new york times magazine can come
up with is well probably he should have
he should have told
corporations to engage in a virtue
signaling okay speaking
of bad messaging so there have been a
bunch of wildfires in california we can
tell that there are a bunch of bad
wildfires in california because we can
look out the windows out here and the
sun
looks particularly orange it looks like
something as people have noted out of
blade runner 2049
it is a really really weird feeling to
walk outside and the entire sky is
covered with smoke it is not
completely unprecedented we've had this
you know every other summer probably for
for several years
the the scale of the fires that are
happening right now
is pretty radical compared to recent
years
this has led democrats to immediately
move into full pagan territory
so here was nancy pelosi yesterday
suggesting that the wildfires are
happening because quote-unquote mother
earth is angry
here is supposedly devout catholic nancy
pelosi talking about the anger of mother
earth which is uh
weird here is nancy pelosi we have
these fires in california and in the
west
of 16 people have died in washington
oregon
and california including a firefighter
and a one-year-old baby
we our firefighters have been so very
very courageous
now we're again breaking records mother
earth is angry she's
telling us whether she's telling us with
hurricanes on the gulf coast
fires in the west whatever it is that
the climate crisis
is real and has an impact okay so it is
not mother earth being angry
okay the climate change does have an
impact on the severity of wildfires but
the major severity of wildfires is due
to bad forest management
michael shellenberger writes over at
forbes magazine
it is not the case that california's
fires have grown more apocalyptic every
year as the new york times reported in
fact in 2019
2019 saw a remarkably small amount of
acreage burn just 280 000 acres compared
to 1.3 million and 1.6 million
in 2017 and 2018 respectively
john keeley a leading foreign scientist
says i see the current california fires
as a normal event just not one that
happens
every year he said on july 30 2008 we
had massive fires throughout northern
california
due to a series of lightning fires in
the middle of the summer it's not an
annual event but it's also not an
unusual
event in fact if you look at areas
burned in california
during prehistoric times many many more
acres were burned
in california in fact keeley notes that
since 1960 the variation in spring and
summer temperatures explain 50
of the variation in fire frequency and
intensity from one year to the next but
the half century since 1960
is the same period in which the us
government promoted mostly out of
ignorance
suppression of regular fires that most
forests need to allow for new growth
it's not just right-wing sources saying
this propublica has an article
by elizabeth weil pointing out that the
prevention of megafires
requires that you allow smaller fires to
actually happen and they have not
allowed it to happen every year
so instead what we keep doing over
zealous fire suppression across
california landscapes where the fire
poses little risk to people and
structures
as a result wildland fuels keep building
up at the same time the climate grows
hotter and drier then boom
the inevitable the wind blows down a
power line or lightning strikes dry
grass and an inferno ensues
this week we've seen both the second and
third largest fires in california
history
so yes prescribed and managed burns that
have been completely ignored by both the
federal and the state government
that would be the major reason why
you're seeing these massive megafires
so again government mismanagement has a
lot to do with what we are seeing in
california and the sort of paganistic
mother earth is angry with us that's why
we're seeing all this
you see this also when there's a
hurricane so when jim inhofe brings a
snowball to the florida senate he says
global warming isn't happening people
mock him when there's a hurricane and
everybody on the left goes this is
because hurricanes are becoming so much
more severe thanks to global warming
nobody has the heart to point out the
reason that hurricanes are more damaging
is because there is more
human structure in the way of those
hurricanes not because the hurricanes
are either more frequent or more
damaging in and of themselves
alrighty so i would be remiss today if i
didn't do a deconstructing the culture
okay it's time for some deconstructing
the culture
okay the the on the menu today is this
film
cuties so i have some complex thoughts
about this film cuties
now cuties is a film that first made
headlines on netflix because
the poster for cuties is supremely
disturbing the way that netflix
originally put it out so netflix put out
a poster of these four little girls i
mean
they are little they're 11 years old
okay and as a father of two daughters
under the age of seven
i can say that the way these girls was
dressed was perverse and disgusting and
pedophilic
and they are dressed completely and
appropriately and horrifically and they
are posing in very sexual imagery
images and all this it's gross and
netflix had to take down the poster
correctly
and then there's the film okay now many
things can be true about the film
simultaneously
one the themes of the film the themes of
the film are
why over sexualization of children are
bad that is the actual theme of the film
okay that now the the honest question to
be asked about the film is when you
cross the line and this has been a long
debated question in film
when you cross the line between
depiction and exploitation this has been
a discussion in american film really
going back to the the end of the haze
code
when you started seeing movies like a
clockwork orange and people were saying
okay
this show's a pretty graphic rape scene
is that exploitation and
and pushing of rape or is it actually
condemnation of rape
you've seen this in the context of
violence where ultra-violent movies
are very often considered glorifications
of the violence rather than
condemnations of it or mere depictions
of it
and so people get very upset about all
this this film falls squarely into that
category
i think you can make a you can certainly
make a fair case that the director in
this particular film
directed the camera in disgusting ways
at 11 year old children
that not only can you make that case i
think that case is fairly obvious
from the actual footage of the film the
question is whether the director is
doing that
in order to make you uncomfortable with
the way these kids are being depicted
because that is part of a pop culture in
which they are
in which they are submerged so the
reason that i bring this up is because i
think a lot of the people
who watch this film who watch the clips
of the film didn't actually watch the
film
and they gave hot takes based on this so
this is why i'm going to provide a
little bit of nuance because i've
actually actually spent the time
yesterday of watching
this this film and it is indeed
incredibly disturbing
and upsetting and uh difficult to watch
so
the clip that was making the rounds
yesterday uh was this clip of these
little girls dancing in very very
sexual ways okay these kids are 11. uh
two of them are of african extraction uh
and or arab extraction one is from
senegal i'm not sure what the other one
is from in the movie
uh and then two of them are uh two of
them are white
uh french again there's a french movie
to explain the context of this clip i
have to explain the plot of the movie so
the plot of the movie is that there is a
little girl her name is emmy
she's 11 years old and she is a muslim
girl
who is living in a fundamentalist
islamic family in paris
her parents her mom is in the movie her
mom is being forced to accept
that the dad is going back to senegal in
order to
bring a second wife right we find this
out 15 minutes into the movie that
they've reserved a bedroom for the
second wife
and that this little girl is being
brought up in a culture that says that
polygamy is good
and that women should be forced to to
accept it thanks to the whim of allah
okay this is made very very clear in the
film this is not me you know
as a quote unquote islamophobe saying
that okay i'm not islamophobe number one
but beyond that
that is not what the film says right so
the film is is
making the point that radical
fundamentalist islamic culture is
anti-woman which happens to be
obviously true right any culture that
says that one wife should be forced to
accept another wife
is in anti-woman culture right that
monogamy is one of the great hallmarks
of judeo-christian civilization in the
west
okay the so she lives in this radical
fundamentalist islamic household
and she's being forced to accept as the
daughter of one woman that she's going
to have like a new stepmom basically
because daddy is off in senegal bringing
back the wife
dad is not present the entire film upset
with her own culture she begins to
engage with a highly sexualized
group of young 11 year old girls the
point of this girls group
is that they are bad people right that
they've been completely misled by the
culture
the parents are not there in any way
shape or form they're basically being
raised by the internet the point of the
film is that these girls are being
raised by the internet
and there are several scenes that prove
this right that these girls are ignorant
about sex that they don't know anything
about sex that all they know about sex
is stuff that they are learning online
there's a scene where they're talking
about the actual biological function of
sex and they literally have no idea what
they're talking about there's a scene in
which one of the girls
finds a used condom in in like in a
forest where they're hanging out
and she blows it up like a balloon
because she literally has no idea what
it is and all the other girls freak out
right these are little girls they're 11.
they're ignorant about sex
but they know what they see online and
what they see online is a bunch of
women grown women who are acting in
extraordinarily hyper-sexualized ways
and they understand that it makes these
women popular
and that the culture values this and so
they start acting in those same ways
now the other girls in the group because
they are sort of more
ensconced in french secular hedonism
they sort of understand where the
appropriate lines are but amy does not
and so she continues to escalate her
behavior to the point where she's taking
shots of her crotch and she's putting
them online the point of the movie she
becomes a worse person
for moving away from fundamental moral
tenets
and moving toward a social media culture
that values women for their sexuality
and values girls for their sexuality and
so she's constantly misinterpreting
things right she there's a scene where
she attempts to sexually proposition
she steals a cell phone from her cousin
who's an adult she
attempts to sexually proposition him in
order to get back the cell phone he of
course reacts very badly because she's
11.
and the point is that she doesn't know
where any of the lines are because she's
being raised by the internet because the
internet
the internet and our over-sexualized
culture deliberately
forces the internalization of
hypersexualization into young teens into
preteens
there's a scene that is described in a
lot of the descriptions in which a 16 or
17 year old girl
shows her uh breast on screen that's
because the girls
in the movie are watching this happen
online they're watching that video
online
and they don't at any point say is what
the girl is doing right or wrong
instead they just say wow look how many
likes she has maybe we should do stuff
like that
okay so the point of the movie is that
france has basically broken down into a
society where because of its
multicultural ethos
it tolerates radical fundamentalist
islam in which people are shipping in
second wives from senegal
on the one hand and on the other hand is
providing as a lived alternative
the secular hedonistic lifestyle that
over sexualizes children
and that there's bleed bleed-over effect
from that sexualist that over-sexualized
lifestyle from adults to children
so that's a pretty conservative message
like the actual message of the film
is actually quite conservative now the
problem with the film comes in
in the depiction right does this film
cross the line between depiction and
exploitation
so there's a clip going around yesterday
of these girls dancing it is you know
warning spoiler warning and and not only
spoiler warning like
nausea warning right now this clip is
graphic it is a graphic clip of these
girls dancing in very sexual ways they
are 11 years old it's disgusting
it is meant to be disgusting okay and
i'll show you kind of
why it's meant to be disgusting okay so
here is the
here's the clip that was going around
yesterday and people were rightly
outraged at this clip
i don't care okay you can see the adults
reacting in the clip
not being upset that these girls are
twerking not being upset and being kind
of
happy about it and these girls are
dancing very very sexually they're 11
years old it's really
really disturbing for folks who can't
see this you know and there are shots of
crotches and shots of butts
okay and it is these kinds of shots that
people are saying how in the world
is this being promoted how in the world
is it even being filmed i mean these are
11 year old girls in real life are being
exploited this way you can see the
adults are very excited about it they're
very happy about it
okay and then the girls start to get
more and more sexual
right and they start to get more and
more sexual because they have
coordinated the stands
based on the based on a video that
they've seen online that is very much
like whap
okay like these very sexualized
hypersexualized lesbianic dances
that's that's a scene in the film
there's a scene in the film where the
main character who is
again the senegalese girl is literally
sitting in a session with the other
women the other women
have scarves over their head and they're
praying and she's sitting with her
earphones in watching this
sexualized hyper-lesbian stuff right on
her cell phone
as that scene goes on you start to see
cutaways of the crowd and the crowd
starts to get more and more disquieted
because people in the crowd are
realizing this is really over the top
this is really really bad
the end of the scene which was cut off
online was cut off for a reason
at the end of the scene is this girl the
main character weeping openly
and stopping the dance because she
realizes that she has been exploiting
herself that she has made herself a
worse person
she runs away from the dance the end of
the film is her
rejecting both the second wedding for
her father and the hyper sexualized
culture
in favor of sort of this generic
childhood innocence she puts on a
sweater that kind of buttons all the way
up to the neck because
it's supposed to be modest and then she
goes and she jump ropes to try and
regain her innocence right that's the
end of the film
so several things can be true at once
and i think it's important to actually
you know watch things before you analyze
what they are about
this may not justify why the film was
made
okay the director of the film by the way
has openly said that the reason the film
was made is because she was walking she
was
a black woman who was of senegalese
descent and grew up in a in an islamic
household
she said she was walking through the
park in france and she saw a group of 11
year-old
year olds dancing like this and she
decided that and she said she was
sickened by it she
says and so she decided to make a movie
trying to explore what in the world
as a culture would we get to the point
where 11 year olds are dancing like this
and she's talked about this openly in
interviews so several things can be true
at once one
i don't think the director meant to
hyper-sexualize the girls for the
pleasure of pedophiles
two netflix definitely with its original
poster hypersexualized the girls for the
purpose of pedophile
netflix their original poster was really
really bad three
the theme of the movie is that
hypersexualization of children is not
only bad but that it springs from an
adult culture that suggests that consent
is the only value
and that bleeds down to people for whom
consent is not possible in ways that
they don't themselves understand that
the hypersexualization of a society does
bleed down to kids that is a theme of
the film
third that a culture that that allows
for
no choice but a choice between a
hyper-sexualized sexual secular
humanistic
vision of hedonism on the one hand and
islamic fundamentalism on the other
is a society that is fated for the
garbage can right that is a point that
the movie is
pretty openly making now the critics
because critics
mainly hate the right and the the
critics have sinned here too
because the critics mostly hate the
right they've decided that this is a
story of female empowerment
through leaving islamic fundamentalism
in favor of twerking that's not what the
film is about the director said that's
not what the film is about
okay the real the real question that
should be asked here is should a film
like this
even be made despite the messaging if it
has to depict images like this in order
to be made i think that's a fair
question
i think it's a fair question i think
it's a very fair question to ask whether
the film
has to depict as much of this as it does
in order to achieve its purpose
the director would probably tell you
that her purpose in showing this stuff
was to make you uncomfortable
was to it was to deliberately make the
viewer uncomfortable so you realize that
so many people are complicit in this
culture that bleeds down to little girls
i guess that's what the director would
say does that
justify the behavior i i think the case
can be made that
it certainly does not that
eleven-year-old goals were 11 year old
girls no matter what you believe were
actually
exploited in the same way that that
brook shields was exploited at 12 when
she was forced to get naked in like blue
lagoon
i think that case can be made but i
think again that it is important to
recognize
what the movie is what it was meant to
be and what it and what it kind of isn't
so that you can have a more fully
rounded discussion about now should you
watch it
i don't think so not unless you're
willing to take you know an hour and a
half of being
clubbed about the ears by some of that
imagery which again is supremely
disturbing
but is it possible for somebody to say
that they think that the messages of the
film are not about pedophilia
i i mean it's pretty obvious the
messages of the film are not about
pedophilia so there is a fully rounded
shaded version of what exactly
cuties was about now does netflix
deserve to be boycotted
for airing cuties well it's directed at
mature audiences it specifically
says that on the film netflix should
have been boycotted over its original
poster
and there are a lot of films on netflix
that depict really bad stuff
the original poster was the problem okay
the film itself
can be a problem i can certainly see why
you would think that that it shouldn't
have been made in the first place and
that should have been receiving
this sort of glorious coverage on the
basis of the images that it glorifies
right even if it was doing so in order
to make you uncomfortable did it have to
do that in order to make the point i
think
john nolte's said this i think he's
probably correct it didn't need to go
this far in order to make the point
i totally get that i kind of agree with
it the poster was the real problem
because the poster obviously
was directed at glorifying the sexual
excess of children
that was the real problem okay so now
you have your movie guide
to cuties it's a little more complicated
than i think most of the takes you're
gonna get
on it um but i think that you know in
all essence we should we should try to
be fair
when we watch these movies and note
where they are wrong
and where they are evil and where
they're making an overall not terrible
point
the movie can be exploitative and bad in
the way that people view it and it can
also be making a fairly good point
actually
about the destruction of a culture that
has no centralizing principles rooted in
virtue and morality
alrighty we'll be back here a little bit
later today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we'll see you here
on monday don't forget to tune in to the
sunday special got dan bongino this week
otherwise we'll see you
here on monday this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavet audio
mix by mike caromina
hair and makeup is by nico geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
you know the matte wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about hope
you'll give it a listen